i actually thought he was gonna walk off
and i'll see him look at me
and he he had a fault and now i know
what the fault was
i've gotta kill him and he just walked
up to me and he just went
bang
[Music]
my childhood was just feral
i'd say it was just a normal average
childhood being brought up beaten
bad abused neglected and abandoned
really
sort of opening fridges and cupboards
and there's no food getting bread out of
the thing and it's all mouldy
you know like thinking why can't why
can't my mum be like everybody else why
can't we be like everybody else
and i was always brought up early up
until about
11 that i had that mindset why can't we
be like everybody else why have we got
to go with that
why don't we eat the same stuff why
don't we buy the same stuff why why is
this why is that
so i was very confused growing up as a
kid
when you look back at that night why do
you think you could you're
it wasn't like anyone else was it just
lack of money or was it just your
mom and dad were in a different way
um obviously i know my dad might i've
seen my dad in my house
there's there's mounds of money there's
mounds of drugs there's 20 30 people in
my house
doing packaging up gear packaging that
money like these are things i see as a
baby right
so i know everyone's crooked i know my
dad's dodgy i've seen guns in my ass
like we're not stupid we know i know my
dad's no good
and my mum's always higher like i want
you to go shopping my mum i
used to put clothes on put jackets on my
mum would say wait outside with this
like look fill up a bag and it's all
right go and wait outside me i'll be out
in a minute
and you know what they're doing and i
just thought everyone done this
shoplifting and thieving
so i've been caught shoplifting by a
store detective they took me home to my
dad
and basically when we've come home
the man's knocked on the door he's going
to be uh we caught your son shoplifting
um we don't want to do it again we'll
phone the police
my dad punched me in the face dragged me
in the house the geez has even gone i
might make calm down calm down and i
remember him saying calm down
my dad's then got rid of the store
detectives and then he's dragged me down
the [ __ ] passageway and he drove me
into the kitchen and just turned on the
[ __ ] fire the gas fire
and then just burnt my hand like and i'm
thinking
i love you you love me why are you
burning my hand like
what are you doing like why dad please
please please
in my head i'm screaming screaming
screaming physically i'm screaming
please
dad please then he's burning i can smell
it you can see it and i'm thinking wow
and then he beat me with a belt and then
he took me back into the kitchen and
made me heat
two massive spoons of becoming hot
pepper sauce and told me if i have a
fever again
i'll be getting twice as much and i went
in my bedroom that night
and i cried and i sobbed and i thought
why would my dad do that to me
like why would my dad do that to me
why would you do that to me i just look
but [ __ ] show you i'll show you and
that was it
from that point i just i had no respect
for anybody after that point like and it
was just
i'm never going to be like you i'm never
going to listen to you i'm never going
to do what you want
you're never going to hurt me and that
was eight years of age
i never understood why i got all the
beats i never understood any of it all
my life and i just grew up
with a real deep hatred towards
anything and everybody when did you
start then
dabbling in criminal activity
my dad would have my house he had my
mum's ass
and in the front room there would be a
mound and i'm talking like
from that wall to that wall like a mound
a mound of weed a little stack of ash
and then they'd be sitting there putting
in five pound draws
little strips loads of strips loads of
strips loads of strips loads of bags
loads of bags and they put them in
little
little packs and then packs will go into
black bags and then basically what i
used to nick them all
right because they don't i just think
they're never going to know these are
missing so when they're turning up and
the people say no that was liar
i never got that this was doesn't have
an argument so my dad's come back to my
mum's
he knows it i know it's you it's got to
be you
it's got to be you you're [ __ ] i can
hear him upstairs
and he's beating my mum beating my mum
but i'm sitting in a room
with i can't remember who's three or
four of my mates
but this path that my mom's getting
beaten for
we're all selling you know i mean we're
all selling it like
what the [ __ ] like we need to come on
man let's stop let's stop him
and they're like marvish your dad i was
like so what he's beating my mum we've
got the puff broth
and they're like oh what are we gonna do
and i was like
and there was a bayonet and a big bang
in my room so i picked the bait i said
i've got a [ __ ] bang
so i've run down the stairs i've run it
through the kitchen door and put the
blade right through his nose he's
[ __ ] touch her again i'll kill you
and he's like put his head back but when
i see him put his head back i thought
oh he hit himself so i pushed him like
that and he's gone
moved backwards i thought yeah yeah get
out of my house you mug
gets out of my house and i sort of ed's
demand and he sort of
walked backwards and i'm thinking wow
he's a mug he's a mug come on get out
guitar my actually
get out so you come back here i'll kill
you stone dead your mug now [ __ ] off
and then my mum was like son so i said
no he can't come back in
and then he's gone never said a word and
when so now i'm thinking
what do i do i've got to let him know
i've got to let him know
he can't come back here so i said to my
father will you drive me up there
because i weren't driving then
i could drive but only in first and
second gear i didn't know about third
and fourth
because i was only young so i said my
will you drive medic because it was a
bit of a way away wilsdon from kilburn
in a car
you're going to get a stop but long
distances my mate's driving me short
distances
i used to nick little cars and go first
gear and second gear
but make sure i said right okay we've
got guys what are you gonna do i said
i'll
put this in my dad's face mate in front
of his mates he said for what
i said just let him know he can't come
back to my ass brother i'll [ __ ] blow
his head off me
and then like marv you're mad mate
you're you're like everyone's trying to
talk me out of this stuff like
everyone's always trying to talk me
and i'm like nah it's happening i don't
give a [ __ ] bro
yeah i've run him out the ass he can't
come back now he needs to know
i'm the man of this house now come and
let's go somebody got in the car driver
over there
and i've walked in and i've just thought
my dad's sitting around the table
playing kaluki with his mates and i just
walked in
and he know he went all right son and i
never said nothing
and i walked behind him and he went are
you right son
and i'll just come there and i'll back
the finger i said no i'm not [ __ ] all
right dad
i'm not all right yeah i'll say i will
be right once you stop coming to my
[ __ ]
ass though he's like what are you
talking about i said you gotta stop
coming to my house do you understand me
and one of his mates has started like i
don't know wherever he thought it was a
joke or not
but he's made i can't remember exactly
what he said but he said something to my
dad i just
said she you [ __ ] say one more word
i'll blow your [ __ ] lips off me
and then the whole room just went quiet
and my dad said
please son please son i was like please
please after what you've done to my
[ __ ] mum yeah don't ever come back to
my ass do you understand me mate
and he was like okay okay and that was
it i'd come out
went downstairs got in the car and went
about my business but that's
me becoming a man was there a moment you
crossed
a line into being okay now i'm in the
criminal world here
it was all 60 yeah 16 or 17 years of age
it was
um basically it's we've had a little bit
of conflict in our area right so
someone's bought a couple of these off
one of my mates
these ease was a little bit trippy right
so after these keys have gone out
totally he's got buzzing got out of the
nut
tripped out a little bit they've come
back said they want their money back my
mate's like
for what it was like that was a bit
trippy my side last night i picked off
your [ __ ] idiot
they're trippy pills what for me to do
cut along social they beat my mate up
my mates drive retaliate got beat up
again so i'm driving down
have a stock hill and on the right hand
and right hand side of having
stockholders used to be a uh
was it's a theater now he's with the
roundhouse theater
i'm driving past i've seen an old friend
they've flagged me down my
mouth all them a lot are in there how
many so he said
seven or eight i said sweet sweet sweet
i'll be back in a minute
run the phone box run my mate he's on i
said right stay in i'll be back
boom flew around his ass survived
where's the ammonia so he's got a bottle
of ammonia
he's got a big blade and a baseball bat
i said right let's go
i've got one skinny little mate and one
short little mate two little white kids
so when we've gone in this um the
verandas i've located a little firm so
there's
seven or eight of them in the back
corner so i've said like
back in the day you should wear bandanas
and mad hats so i said to
one of my mates mick you wear this you
wear that and you slip over
when you're there let me know because
this used to mean
that's sweet that's that that sign there
that's just sweet so back
backwards is sweet forward as he's on
top that's it's on top knit
knit knit backwards means sweet so i
said give us the sign so
sweet so he's got over there he's give
us a sign so now i'm coming
so i said when you see me coming you
just start doing them all
with ammonia once you've done them with
ammonia i'll put the ones down on the
floor with the bat that we want
and then we have a little mate getting
well
yeah gingwell's come in and just done
all the main ones
that we needed to do right and then we
asked them
do you want to end it do you want to end
it now please please please please
please
it's done yeah it's done it's done now
we're
we're we've done the firm we've done
we've done we've done a lot of them mate
we've done them all
done put them on the floor plans them
out they're done so now we're buzzing
we're the governors of the little man in
there
can you just list off from the things
you were doing what were the kind of
activities
i've been under investigation i think
for
24
24 murders um
seven or eight shootings and maybe
30 40 armed robberies i've been under
investigation before i've had
observations
put on me for years
for years and
i got arrested for lots i got punished
for lots
and i got away with lots once i went
over 30
it was just another level it was just
another level like when we started doing
30 45 we started doing all the drugs and
things like that it's
it's unreal
it's unreal but then the backstabbing
sneaking cheating robin
conniving ah
that there's lots of money out it's
beyond but then there's millions of rat
bags snake
that will rob you sell you shoot you
kill you bury you
and they will do it and then they're
your closest people yeah your closest
people
are the only people that can damage you
so your closest friends will rob you
they'll set you up to get robbed they'll
set you up to get killed
i know three major gangsters gangsters
right major gangsters
they've killed their partners to take
over their graft
west london they're famous for killing
their elders which i mean they're taking
their parcels and everybody knows what
i'm talking about
james answer but they're famous for it
they've done it in north london as well
and west london and they've done it they
iron out their people to take their bits
which i'm saying so you're not safe even
by the people you grow with
what's the closest you've been to to
death
i used to have a driver used to drive me
about everywhere and pick me up drop me
off pick me up
drive me around the place i should give
him a percentage of stuff i used to make
so if i made money my driver would get a
percentage of what i made just for being
there and driving me about
anyway i'm talking to drive around my
mate's house one day my mom excites to
be uh
i also have all the watches in the world
so i've got my mate's house he's got a
load of watches mark do you want this
one i said i'm all right for watching a
minute
so my driver said i want one could i get
one
so my mate said is he all right i said
yeah he sweets a lot
i pay his wages get him every once
monday's come
he's been giving his money i'll actually
assume he's going to pay my mate for the
watch gun amount of business
a couple of things have happened about a
month later my mates wrote me up
and said hello marv what's happening son
i said oh i made you
he said yeah he said i'm a little bit
disappointed marvel i said why is that
he said i was just wondering if you're
going to be paying for that watch
anytime soon
why didn't he pay for that cheeky
hello mate listen you need to go around
and paint without watching my eyes and
punch your
head in your little can't pay for the
watch what's the matter with you
what what you think because we're not
having it you think you can not pay for
the watch
go and pay for the watch i'll punch your
[ __ ] head in your little
he's what's he gonna do with you what
what do you mean you cheeky it's my
powers watch take it back otherwise i
want to punch a [ __ ] head in
he said he's got nothing to do with you
why are you getting involved i said
right you little where
are you where are you i said i'm down
paul bernous i said i'll be down in a
minute
so i've jumped in the mower and the
ironic thing about he had a 357 magnum
on me
i took it out sent to me if you hold on
to that i'll be back in a minute where
you going
i said down the pool i've got slap this
[ __ ] head in
so i've jumped into my flu down here as
i've pulled up got out the car he's not
there so i've seen his mate i said
where's your pal
he said we ain't here i said i know he
ain't [ __ ] here where is he
he's only be back in a minute so i've
naturally assumed he's going to get at
all
sweet not a problem i think i'll sit
down and wait with you then i said you
know what this little mug's all about
i said because he owes money did he tell
you owes me money he said well no he
never
what for i said for a [ __ ] watch mate
he said you know what mate
why don't you go home and i'll bring him
up the gym tomorrow i said no because if
he's going to get a [ __ ] tool he can
use it when he comes back to mug
what he said no no go and go i said no
[ __ ] that if he's got a tool he's going
to use you when he comes back
i'll punch his [ __ ] head in with that
in comes mark so he's come walking up so
i've seen him i'll jump so i said
coming in let's go mate well he's like
he showed me a gun i was like what else
are you going to do with that
so now i've walked away from him i've
seen the gun so i've turned around in my
head i've just got to get close enough
to grab the gun off him because
i didn't believe he would shoot me i
just believed he
would wave about screaming maybe try
pistol with me or do something
so i thought as long as i can get closer
i'll just smash
alien and shoot right so i'm thinking
get close to him
as i've got i say two or three
arms away from him he's pulled the gun
out
so i'm locking him in the eyes so i'm
just walking towards him i said mate
if you've come to use it do what you
come to do bruv yeah
and i didn't think he did i thought i'd
get i was maybe
three steps away from grabbing the gun
and i took two steps and he shot me in
this leg
and as he shot me in his leg it just
disintegrated and i've hit the deck
and then basically when he's even like i
thought you
[ __ ] mug obviously you're angry you
you
[ __ ] do your job you mug and he walks
over he's done me again and then he's
done me again
and it was after the third shot that i
thought to myself you know what
keep your mouth shut son keep your mouth
shut say nothing
say nothing and then i actually thought
he was gonna walk off
and i'll see him look at me and he he
had a fault
and now i know what the fault was he
said this
is gonna kill me i've gotta kill him and
he just walked up to me
and he just went bang bang straight in
the head but the first one
as me ed's gone battlefield oh my god
this guy just shot me in the face
i can't believe it i'm going to die i
thought
i could still hear something and i've
opened my eye and i thought wow
and i've seen the barrel the gun and i
thought what the [ __ ]
and then i'll just see the bullet coming
towards me and that's when i've heard
the bang
and i was like oh my god this no way can
he kill me i'm two weeks old he's got
his belly button pierced he's got his
nipple pierced he's got his tongue bears
how the [ __ ] can i get killed by this
bam
and then about footsteps running off and
i was like
i've gone like that my knob is just
splattered all over my pants
like my leg there was no blood like in
blood but
it was just all fleshy like everything
was just flesh open
and i was like wow for some reason i
thought i was going to go into shock
so i'm breathing breathing breathing
breathing brim i'm on the phone
right listen silly she's dummy you know
i don't know how many times done me but
because when a gun fires it makes two
boom boom boom boom for one shot so i
said i don't know how many times he shot
me he shot me a few times mate
i don't know he said but he shot me in
my face and my face my face i can't feel
my face i can't feel my face i don't
know how many times you shot me mate
so there's one bullet hole there and
then once right in the eye
and the inside of my eye you can see
i've still got my retina and i've still
got my optic nerve and you can see it
all moving at the back
because the bullet stopped halfway
through my eye and they don't know what
stopped it
and it flattened flat as a pancake so i
mean my female archers got planted in
three places i never bled
they told me i'll never walk again first
i actually thought i was dead
and then i've heard someone say marvin
is that you and i literally
please believe me i literally thought i
was in heaven
i thought i tried ringing ambulance
what's happened i said i've been shot
okay where
i said right i've got twice one's in the
leg one's in my groin
one's in my arm and twice in my head
silence hung up
hello hello hello i've done this three
times before the police had to ring them
back
i'm saying no no no it's true it's true
it's true
you had all the difference but what was
the thing that made you go straight
a lot of my youngsters i still groomed
them so they made money for me
if i paid 15 grand for something but i
could sell it for 30 grand in this
country
then i'd give it to my youngsters for 17
000.
so the transport gets paid the storage
gets paid and then they make the money i
don't make the money
to understand but they've got to return
the money to buy the product
right so this kid he's getting his money
again
but he owes hundreds of thousands of
pounds and i'm thinking how
how how how could he owe this much money
like it don't make sense
it was as simple as this little taking a
piss shoot him
simple right listen do me a favor i need
you to go and light someone up for me
where well i don't want him dead just do
his legs
nothing above the waist four or five
sweet not a problem
where's he from kent is tan
sure i'll do me a favor please make sure
you find out who he is
before you do anything
ping ping ping ping hello mate what's
happening oh you'll never guess what
what's up you see that fella yeah what
fella
because you've asked me to find yeah
he's only best mates with your son
you're dying i was like what what the
[ __ ] he said yeah his
pals with him you know i was like damn
so i'm almost done do you know this
fella he said yeah i said can you get me
his number he said yeah
so i rang him up i said well you need to
come and see me gee come and see me i
said look no disrespect g but
that money you owe yeah i don't know no
money i said yes you do you said i don't
i went
ping ping ping ping i said yes you do
and it's me
and he's like i said well i'm going to
do you a favor
i said because i can't do this no more i
said i'm hurting and damaging and
killing youngsters mate it can't happen
so
i want to give you an opportunity yeah
i'm coming off the road today right now
i'm coming off i'm not doing this graph
no more at all
if you don't want to pay me back that
money yeah come off the vote with me
today
if you want to pay me back then i'm
going to sell that debt
to somebody that you won't like and they
won't be as lenient with me and
they will hurt you he said well what am
i going to do i said i don't know what
you're going to do i said well i'm
coming off the road today i'm going to
the gym for the next six months and i
guarantee something else will turn
around
he's gone off he's developed a music
platform recording studio record label
now he's got four or five artists under
him turning over just hundred million
pound a yeah
do you understand i'm an advocate
against crime
a mentor peer mentor motivational
speaker personal trainer personal coach
and life speaking life coach
yeah that was the turning point into
what we do and now we're going to
schools colleges and prisons
and i just sort of ask the kids for what
what are you doing why are you doing it
where's your role where's your game
where's your goal
like what's your objective you've turned
your life around now
you've gone you're you're you're trying
to help people and all this no no i'm
not trying to help you guys
i'm helping everybody like i'm helping
everybody i come into contact with
there's no trying
i do what i do look back on your
life of crime and regret it
see i do what i've done
right because
i regret the choices that i made and i
regret
the loyalty that i give i regret
sacrificing for so many scumbags the
thing that these youngsters got to
understand
it all these people you do that tell you
they love you
yeah i love you cuz fam fam they don't
[ __ ] love you
that's the thing and when you get older
you'll realize but
the one thing i regret is supporting
loving and sacrificing for the scumbag
grooming
[ __ ] bags because that's all they are
bad grooming nonsense
like how to could you give a 14 year old
kid a gun like what the [ __ ]
like i get angry with these [ __ ] i'm
saying you like you think
i'll take accountability for what i've
done because i wanted to be the baddest
villain on the planet when i walked
anywhere
people said do you know what it is
and when i turn around people put their
heads down
so i mean that was my buzz i was so
egotistical
and and no matter how hard you was but
if they ever owed me money
they even they'd tell you i'd [ __ ] them
up
you know do you regret the
the hurt and the pain that i suffered
made up would suffer yeah because this
is irony of that right now
i regret everything i'd done even
shooting some people after i'd done it
i'd be like
um that was a libby they didn't even
deserve that
[ __ ] they chose this life that's the
life that's the life
it's the life so i always put everything
down i always felt bad
i felt bad even b look people out there
watching this now no
yeah you know i've apologized to you you
know i've come to your house you know
i've
begged forgiveness off you yeah you know
this because every single person i've
done something to
i've gone back to them and said look i
never meant to do that even
one of the worst the last shooting i was
investigated for i've actually spoke to
the kid
that was involved in the shooting and
tried to rectify
the relationship and rebuild from a
different place as two different people
he was
very forgiving and it was nice
and he was he i said i've really got to
apologize man i said my mate we was all
[ __ ] lunatics back then broth
he said come on mate if i'll have got
you out of got you me
he said you just got me first brother
and i was like nah i ain't
you don't know this and you don't know
he said marvin don't [ __ ] matter mate
it was all lunatics it was all wild you
caught for me they caught for me this
happened that happened what the [ __ ]
he said how did you feel about it he's
gonna shot you i said ah i feel sorry
for him mate he said but that's how i
feel oh don't drive yourself mad
so i mean i actually feel sorry for the
kid that shot me because he will never
be at peace
thinking i'm coming from you know but
you're happy you don't want to get into
it's like
you're in a happy place i may i'm i'm a
listen i'm happy
when i get male right i'm happy that i'm
registered at our house
i'm happy that i'll get male i'm happy
that i've paid taxes
i'm happy that i'm going to leave here
get in my car and i'm going to drive
and i don't have to worry about blue
lights when i hear from simon i don't
even look anymore
do you understand like i've got i'm free
i'm free
i'm free and there is no better feeling
on this planet than being
free
[Music]
that lad wasn't on that wing very long
he went to the gym one day someone found
out
what he'd done um i remember the lad
and he hit him with a dumbbell in the
face
he went to hospital and i never saw him
again